يدق الجرس البئر فوق 200
أعوام
خلال تاريخها المسبك
صنع paccard حوالي 120 ألف
جيوب و no الجرس يرن في
العالم كله
تايبيه
أنا
اسمي حجر ليس لأنني هنا
الجيل السادس من المسبك
paccard اسمي فيليب ليس لأنني
أنا الجيل السابع من
مسبك باكارد ، اسمي كليمنت
ليس لأنني من الجيل الثامن
من مسبك paccard تاريخ
تبدأ أوقات باكارد يوم الإثنين 696
عندما كان من الضروري إعادة البناء
كل التراث الأجراس
دمرتها الثورة في فرنسا
الفرنسية
قال جدي وها هو
لماذا لا يا مؤسسي الجرس
تم هذا الإرسال من
باستمرار كل الأجيال
حتى يومنا هذا
ذهب العديد من الأجراس
في الخارج يوجد أكثر من 10000 جرس
في كندا نرى أكثر من 10000
أكبر المشاركات في الولايات المتحدة
يسمى الجرس جرس السلام العالمي الذي
جعل الجرس الأكبر
رحلة من العالم
هذا ما اعتقدته
كل دقيقة تمر أ
تحقق من علامة Packard mason moors
[موسيقى]
أجراس البيت
باكارد اليوم دائما
مصنوعة باستخدام نفس التقنية
أنه يمكن أن يكون عند الخلق
الشركة التي تعتمد عليها هذه المعرفة
ثلاث خصائص أساسية
الملف الشخصي أو شكل الجرس
جودة المعدن الأجراس في الواقع
البرونز
ثم المعلمة الثالثة
المهم هو القدرة على وضع
موالف
صوت الجرس هو صوتنا الرئيسي
محاطة بالعديد من التوافقيات و
من صوت جرس جميل عليه
يجب أن تكون التوافقيات مثالية
منسجمة بينها وبيننا نحن هنا
أمام فرن 4 طن يذهب
تسخين المعدن مباشرة
[موسيقى]
الجزء المفضل لدي من العملية جيدًا
أود أن أقول أنه لا يزال المطر
[موسيقى]
تشعر بحرارة المعدن المنصهر
نراه يتدفق في القالب و
لذا فهي حقًا لحظة لم يحدث ذلك
ألم عاطفية ومن جميل جدا
[موسيقى]
سأكون ستة أو سبعة عندما
لقد بدأت حقًا في الركض
مقاولة
كل هذا اليوم عمري 16 سنة
لذلك ما زلت في المدرسة
لذلك لا يمكنني العمل كل يوم
أيام في الشركة ذوبان أ
الجرس لا نرى الكثير في
العالم استثنائي وهذا ما لدي
كانت هذه المهنة دائمًا منذ ذلك الحين
منذ أن كنت صغيرا قلت لنفسي هو
لا بد لي من العمل هنا
أشعر بالفخر لأن أطفالي
يمكن أن تستمر في التقليد الذي
المهم هو أنه يواجه أ
الفرح العظيم هو الدافع العظيم
بمهنة الشغف واللعب والطرح
تأثير ضبابي أن الجدار لا يزال أجراسًا
سنوات عديدة
[موسيقى]